china's covid zero policy is now a long
way from zero
this is a vast new quarantine center in
shanghai where covert patients are sent
they are not allowed to isolate at home
and there will surely be more to come as
the city locks down in two stages of
four days each to test every last one of
its 26 million inhabitants
but some facilities are already
struggling with the demand it's more
than two years since kovid first emerged
in china much of the world is moving on
there is no end in sight here
rebecca lynn has already spent 10 days
in a targeted localized lockdown at home
the login guy is more serious than
before the locking down for
all the plays in the same times
is very
hard so
[Music]
i can understand what situation we are
facing now
this is a serious test of the cost of
kovitzero when shanghai announced the
lockdown supermarkets were swamped
shelves emptied
fights broke out for the food that
remained
shanghai is in the middle of the omicron
storm right now but this is a nationwide
challenge for the central authorities
here in beijing the costs of zero covid
are becoming increasingly clear but the
cost of the alternative may be even
higher
china has kept covert numbers very low
over the last two years but because of
that apparent safety a large portion of
the elderly population are not fully
vaccinated
if they could actually raise these
vaccination rate then
they should actually at least gradually
reverse these zero kobe policy so that
um
they could actually uh
maybe going towards
towards uh living with the virus with
chinese characteristics
the shanghai lockdown is an attempt to
buy time especially time to vaccinate
more people it is the only thing that
can break the seemingly never-ending
cycle of lockdown test repeat tom
cheshire sky news beijing